Dan mentioned the idea of using
widgets to bring our Sunshine data
directly to the user's home screen.
What exactly is a widget?
So far, we've only focused on
activities, full screen experiences, and
fragments, which are reusable
portions of those activities.
Widgets differ in that area
provides just the view.
That view is then passed
to the home screen app,
the launcher to display alongside other
widgets and other app launcher icons.
App widgets had a humble beginning.
Fixed-size widgets that could
respond to one action, tapping.
It was great for control widgets or
widgets with just a single piece
of information to display.
In Android 3, widgets got support for
collections of data and
vertical swiping.
Now, you can display a stack, list,
or grid of data right in your widget,
making it easy to jump into exactly
the piece of information you need.
Android 3.1 opened up the possibility
of resizing your widget either
horizontally, vertically, or both.
This gave users the ability to customize
exactly how much space they want
to give to your widget, and
gave developers the tools needed to
customize how they display their data
depending on the size of the widget.
So, can we use these capabilities for
Sunshine?
Let's focus on two common cases.
Today's weather, where we'll build
a horizontally resizable widget,
showing information just about today.
And the weather forecast,
where we'll build a detail widget,
which will display the same data we
see in the main screen of Sunshine,
to give users quick access to their
forecast, right from the home screen.
So let's get started.